تتعرض العاصمه الاوكرانيه لاحدى اوسع
الهجمات الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب تقول سلطات
هناك ان دفاعتها الجويه اسقطت 37 صاروخا
من اصل 40 استهدفت العاصمه لم تكن كيف
وحيده اليوم تحت القصف الروسي ثاني اكبر
المقاطعات الاوكرانيه اخر كيب شرقي البلاد
زبوجيا ميكولاي بوديس في الجنوب تعرضت
لهجمات الروسيه واسعه النطاق اكثر من 60
صاروخا روسيا اطلقت اليوم على اوكرانيا
اهداف القوات الروسيه تتركز على البنيه
التحتيه ومنشات الطاقه بشكل اساسي بينما
يدق الشتاء ابوابات تلك المناطق البارده
اصلا تتضرر بقصف اليوم 9 منشات للطاقه
الاوكرانيه يكون لهذه الضربات اهداف على
المدى المتوسط والبعيد تريد موسكو ان يكون
شتاء ثقيلا على الاوكرانيين هكذا تركيه في
الامر
تحولت محطه القطار الى ملاجئ مؤقته وحل
الظلام في معظم المدن الاوكرانيه
اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه العمل بنظام
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي الطارئ في جميع
انحاء البلاد بسبب استهداف منشات الطاقه
رغم كل ذلك تقول القوات الاوكرانيه ان
دفاعتها الجويه تصدت لمعظم الصواريخ
الروسيه هنا يتصدر المشهد مطالباتك ايفل
الغرب في المزيد من منظومات الدفاع الجوي
لصد الهجمات الروسيه
باتريوت كلمه السر التي تبحث عنها كياب من
واشنطن بامكان هذه المنظومه ان تغير في
المعادله وان تمنح الاوكرانيين تفوقا
يمنحهم شتاء اقل بردا توجد منظومه باتريوت
التي تعمل على تامين المجال الجوي لدول
نيته في اوروبا الشرقيه في رومانيا
وبولندا وكذلك في دور اوروبيه اخرى
كالمانيا وهولندا واسبانيا وضعت واشنطن
لمسات الاخيره على تزويديه
من التفاصيل الفنيه
او اي من المستشارين او المدربين الغربيين
المتوقع وصولهم الى اوكرانيا لتدريب الجيش
هنا هكذا تقترب الحرب من طي شهرها العاشر
تزداد توتر مع تاثيرات اوكرانيه من هجوم
روسيا واسع النطاق قبل ان يغلق الشتاء
الطرق المؤديه لاي حسم عسكري في الميدان